I've travelled to Istanbul to meet this
group of entertainers their performance
is an artistic form of rebellion against
the government have become the
soundtrack of a nationwide protest they
call themselves Kadesh to cooler songs
of solidarity
this is a last rehearsal before a major
summer concert I'm here to get a look at
the role Kadesh to cooler plays in the
protest movement why this band of
talented musicians opposes the
government of reg apt I heard one
twenty-six-year-old o'mara gun has been
a member of Kadesh to cooler for years
and is considered one of the best
dancers he's vermin tlie opposed to the
Edwin government and dedicated to
encouraging descent they're really
excited for such a lively performance
that they are going to be seeing it's
not just a concept for them i think when
i see on social media for a couple
comments they say you are going there to
feel the resistance and the protest and
that is kardash circular strong suit
that music is a powerful vocal rejection
of the conservative Islamist government
the group itself is a colorful and
eclectic mix of cultures Kurds and a
lights gays and heterosexuals and one
practicing Muslim
boo mayor takes me to the place that
became world-famous this summer jay-z
park on Taksim Square in the heart of
Istanbul it's empty this evening but a
few months ago it was the scene of
violent confrontations between security
forces and thousands of protestors
several lives were lost and thousands
were injured
back in June there were all tense here
all around here and thousands of people
but the police reoccupied the park now
there is almost no one whenever there is
a protest in around here the park is
closed by the police so it's really the
police's park right now Oh May affairs
confrontation with the security forces
that's why he only comes here after dark
the next day I visit Emmaus apartment
near the Bosporus his roommate Fidel
kill each is a singer with Kadesh tu
culo both are in Gaza park when the
protest movement was in its infancy
young yet Fidel tries to explain why
he's taken to the streets in protest he
says the government is constantly
outlawing things like abortion and
alcohol it wants to force women to have
at least three children no one was doing
anything about it that's why he joined
the demonstrators man says he has become
more careful since this summer at the
time he was protesting every day but now
he's afraid of the police with their
water cannon and teargas large order to
get the relation this all out
five demonstrators have been killed so
far sometimes ogun feels he's abandoning
the other demonstrators to fend for
themselves in the end what he wants most
is to live in peace
later I meet with another band member 24
year old room a surge um Darrell E plays
electric guitar and studies IT in her
free time it's easy to see by the
headscarf that she is a practicing
Muslim I wonder what has brought her to
protest the conservative Islamist
government Canada solution to this this
regime sells itself is the arbiter of
political Islam but nothing could be
further from the truth this government
is neoliberal and favors the status quo
in other words cold hard capitalism I'm
not trying to say that Islam would
foster socialist policies or something
similar but as a Muslim I find it a
shame to see the poor getting poorer and
the rich getting richer that goes
against our religious beliefs listen
that I'm going to lean on room room aces
ideology upsets just about everyone most
fellow Muslims ostracize her because she
takes the stage with homosexuals but she
also ruffled feathers among the
protesters in ghazi park they belittle
her as a government stooge because she
wears a headscarf sartori what tourister
it was awful some people insulted me
outright others greeted me with open
arms as if they were in charge and I was
just a guest that's why I tend to
support the protest movement via
Facebook and through my music I did not
buy that she means the protest songs of
car dash to cooler this evening they
will take the stage in what's billed as
their biggest concert of the summer
kayo la la it will be heavenly people
should believe in themselves again it's
wonderful to be united with so many
supporters of the gauzy protests and
hear the music of car dash to cooler
an estimated four thousand fans attend
Oh baby singer fareal ni fires up the
crown telling them the protests in gezi
Park are proof that they can achieve the
lofty goals of freedom equality and
solidarity
they chant daisy is everywhere Taksim is
everywhere it's a special evening for
the musicians and concert goers alike
what they don't know is that another
demonstrator was killed during clashes
with police the violence took place
several hundred kilometres from Istanbul
the sixth casualties since the protest
movement began
the next day the tension is palpable on
the streets of Istanbul another major
illegal demonstration is scheduled the
police are out in force
many of the band members of Kadesh
circular have left the city for a few
days the demonstrators have vowed to
retake kz park special forces will do
everything in their power to keep that
from happening
the protests start out peacefully
despite the first scent of tear gas
suddenly violence erupts
tear gas Sting's the eyes and burns the
skin this woman has lost track of her
friend in the tumult another says she
feels a special kinship with those who
died in the struggle killed fence
yesterday and and last month six of my
friends
I'll uh
many injuries are reported and dozens
are arrested the demonstrators failed in
their attempt to retake Ghazi Park
security forces maintain control
much of the protest movement is rooted
in the students attending Bosporus
University in Istanbul that includes
room I sir the IT specialist but these
days her studies have taken a backseat
to the demonstrations during rehearsals
for their next concert the band members
discuss the ongoing political movement
and what they can do to help I can't
just pick up my guitar after a
demonstrator is killed I don't even want
to play sad songs I'd rather take to the
streets and demonstrate but our music
plays an important role among the people
so we have to keep going umeå also has
been deeply moved by the events of the
past few days he's taken courage from it
all he's ready to join the protest
movement again it's important to be on
streets I guess and I'll tried it I will
try my best to continue that so I'm
heading that way to the protest
on this day there are no major
confrontations but the police presence
is overwhelming so much has happened
over the past few days Ramez band has
fired up the demonstrators with its
summer concert and he is conquered his
own inner fears but the fear of renewed
violence remains
Oh
No
Oh